>> Sean: WE SHOWED YOU LAST
NIGHT OF PULLING CONDITIONS IN
THE DEMOCRATIC RUN CITY OF
BALTIMORE APPEARED TONIGHT, WE
WANT TO
TELL YOU ABOUT ANOTHER
LIBERAL CITY PRETTY MUCH
DESTROYED KIND OF LIKE
SAN FRANCISCO, RIGHT HERE IN
NANCY PELOSI'S HOUSE IN
LOS ANGELES.
2020 DEMOCRATIC HOPEFULS, THEY
ARE THERE IN DETROIT THIS WEEK
TRYING TO WIN THEIR PARTY'S
NOMINATION.
TO OPPOSE THE GREEN NEW DEAL
DISASTER, WHAT THEY PROBABLY
WON'T TALK ABOUT ARE THE LIBERAL
POLICY FAILURES THAT TOOK PLACE
IN THE MOTOR CITY, NOW GOING ON
DECADES.
ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT
DATA AVAILABLE, DETROIT HAS THE
WORST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE OF ANY
MAJOR U.S. CITY, WHOPPING 8.8%.
AND HAS RAISED THE POVERTY RATE
39.7% FOR THE SECOND HIGHEST
MURDER RATE ONLY BEHIND
BALTIMORE AND THE WORST VIOLENT
CRIME RATE AS WELL.
LAWRENCE JONES, OUR TRAVELING
CORRESPONDENT, IT WAS SENT TO
DETROIT TO SEE WHAT PEOPLE HAVE
TO SAY ABOUT THE WAY THEIR
CITIES BEING RUN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO THE LEADERS, DO YOU THINK
THEY ARE REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY EFFECTIVELY?
>> WHO ARE THEY?
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHO THEIR
LEADERS ARE?
YOU NEVER SEEN THE COMING OUNCE?
>> NO.
IT'S HARD WHEN IT COMES TO
CAMPAIGN TIME.
EVERYONE TALKING A GOOD GAME BUT
NOBODY'S DOING IT.
>> ELECTED OFFICIALS THE
PROVOST'S ALL THIS CHANGE, ARE
THEY DELIVERING?
>> NOT TO ME.
>> TELL ME ABOUT THE KIND HAD >>
ALL MY GOD, SPORT HORRIBLE.
WE JUST HAD FIVE PEOPLE SHOT
LAST NIGHT.
SHOOTING ALWAYS BACK THERE.
MY KIDS SAY DID YOU ALL HEAR THE
GUNFIGHT?
AND THEY JUMPED TO THE FLOOR AND
THAT'S WHERE THEY SLEPT.
THEY REFUSE TO GET BACK IN THE
BED BECAUSE THEY WERE TOO
SCARED.
>> TELL ME ABOUT THE HOUSING
SITUATION HERE.
>> OH, WELL, THE HOUSING --
THEY NEED TO BUILD MORE REC
CENTERS, GIVE SOME BACK CENTERS
TO GIVE THE YOUNG KIDS SOMETHING
TO DO IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THERE WOULDN'T BE SO MUCH CRIME
AROUND HERE.
>> SEE HER GETTING OUT OF HERE?
>> YEAH.
>> WHY?
>> IT'S TIME TO GO.
NOTHING'S HERE.
>> I FEEL BAD THAT I WANT TO GO.
I'VE BEEN HERE 66 YEARS AND I
WANT TO GO.
I'M TIRED OF LOOKING OF THIS
MESS.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW IS
HANNITY SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT
AND INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER, ALSO
WITH US, THE SEAL OF THE
NATIONAL DIVERSITY COALITION FOR
TRAUMA, THAT WOULD BE DARRELL
SCOTT.
I ACTUALLY PREACHED FROM THE
PULPIT OF HIS CHURCH, IT WAS THE
WORST HOUR YOU'VE EVER HEARD BUT
I DID IT.
I TRIED.
LAWRENCE, LET ME SHARE WITH YOU.
I'M WATCHING THE PEOPLE IN
BALTIMORE, I'M WATCHING YOUR
IMPORTS INFANT AT SAN FRANCISCO,
L.A., EVENT OF BALTIMORE, NOW
YOU'RE IN DETROIT.
THOSE ARE OUR FELLOW CITIZENS.
THEY ARE SUFFERING.
AND THEY DESERVE BETTER.
THE QUESTION IS, WHY ARE THE
SAME LIBERAL POLITICIANS ELECTED
EVERY CYCLE?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I DON'T KNOW IT'S IT'S BECAUSE
PEOPLE AREN'T SHOWING UP TO THE
POLLS BUT IT'S A DEPRESSING
STATE HERE.
I WENT TO DETROIT WITHOUT THE
CAMERA CREW AND CAME BACK AN
HOUR LATER AND IT'S A CRIME
SCENE.
A HOMICIDE.
WITHIN AN HOUR OF GOING TO ONE
LOCATION, IT WAS ALREADY A CRIME
SCENE.
WHEN MOTHERS HAVE TO TELL THEIR
KIDS TO SLEEP ON THE FLOOR, CAN
YOU IMAGINE THAT?
FOR THE AUDIENCE OUT THERE
TELLING YOUR KIDS THAT THEY HAVE
TO SLEEP ON THE FLOOR SO THEY
DON'T GET GUNFIRE?
THAT IS A TRAGEDY AND LIKE I
SAID LAST NIGHT, THERE HAS TO BE
AN OPENING FOR CONSERVATIVES AND
REPUBLICANS TO GO ON THESE
COMMUNITIES.
I DON'T THINK THESE PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT MUCH AT THIS POINT.
THEY JUST WANT SOMEONE TO FIX
THE PAIN.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I'VE GOTTEN
TO KNOW YOU.
I FEEL LIKE THE PASTOR IN THE
STREETS AND I KNOW BECAUSE YOU
ASKED ME TO HELP WHENEVER I
COULD AND MY ANSWER IS ALWAYS
YES.
YOU ARE HELPING OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS OUT.
YOU TOOK A LOT OF FOR SUPPORTING
DONALD TRUMP HE HAD A LOT TO HER
BY THE WAY, ANYONE WHO IS
FRIENDS WITH DONALD TRUMP GETS A
FAIR SHARE OF HEAT.
BUT, WE HAVE RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT RIGHT NOW FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THE BEST EMPLOYMENT SITUATION
SINCE 1969.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
HISPANIC-AMERICANS.
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE.
THAT DOESN'T SOUND TO ME LIKE A
RACIST PRESIDENT.
IT THAT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE A
PROBLEM SOLVER WHO IS WILLING TO
CALL OUT A PROBLEM FOR WHAT IT
IS.
AND I THINK DONALD TRUMP TO THE
BED BEST THING THAT BALTIMORE
HAS EVER SEEN BECAUSE NOW WE
KNOW HOW BAD THEY RUN THIS PLAC.
>> YEAH, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
BACK IN 2011, DONALD TRUMP TOLD
ME THAT HE BELIEVED UNEMPLOYMEN
UNEMPLOYMENT, UNDER DEPLOYMENTS,
CONTRIBUTED TO A LOT OF THE
CRIME AND THE DISPARITY THAT
EXISTED IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY
AND THAT IF HE BECAME PRESIDENT,
AND HE SET THIS EIGHT YEARS AGO,
THAT HE WOULD DO WHAT HE COULD
TO ADDRESS THOSE PROBLEMS AND
HE'S DOING IT.
BUT IRVINE BLADE IS A REALITY
THROUGHOUT AMERICA.
THE POLITICIANS SHOW UP EVERY
TWO TO THREE YEARS, THEY SHAKE
THEIR HEAD, THEY PROMISED TO
COME BACK, BUT WIN OR LOSE, THEY
DON'T COME BACK.
AND WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE,
HE IS CALLED THE MAYOR TO
EXAMINE, TO ADDRESS, TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS DEPRESSED
CONDITIONS EXIST IN AMERICA AND
IT HAS TO BE SOMETHING DONE
ABOUT IT AND THAT'S WHY WE
FORMED URBAN REVITALIZATION
COALITION SO THAT WE CAN
REVITALIZE THESE NEIGHBORHOODS.
SUE AND ABSOLUTELY PAY LAWRENCE,